[Musique]
septième numéro de notre rendez vous
hebdomadaire et bientôt quotidien
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix c'est tous
les lundis à 20h15 heure de paris
antoine feu nous ce soir bonsoir bonsoir
anthony donc on le disait cette invasion
russe de l'ukraine elle a forcé certains
candidats à se positionner absolument
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine qui a
largement donc bouleverser la campagne
présidentielle assez logiquement dernier
exemple en date donc cette annulation du
premier meeting de campagne d' emmanuel
macron initialement prévu à marseille ce
week-end là où le président devait donc
se rendre la guerre en ukraine qui a
évidemment changé les priorités on
imagine du locataire de l'elysée elle a
aussi donné lieu vous allez le voir à
des revirements inattendus chez certains
candidats tout ça c'est au programme
durée cap politique de la semaine et il
est signé bilal tarabet et aurélien
porcher
cette année ils voient les vaches maison
coup devant emmanuel macron est un chef
de guerre et le devoir l'appelle il
écourte sa visite au salon de
l'agriculture
cette guerre durera mais l'ensemble des
crises qu'il y aura derrière auront des
conséquences durables il nous faut donc
nous y préparer avec beaucoup de
détermination avec aussi beaucoup de
solidarité
la gare en ukraine bouscule la campagne
présidentielle le reste est inaudible
pour le candidat de debout la france
c'est une tentative de hold up des
manuels macron pour plier la campagne
on a eu la peur du coc vide on a la peur
de l'ukraine et pendant ce temps là on
anesthésie les français à la veille d'un
scrutin absolument vital pour leur
avenir eric zemmour rêvait d'un poutine
français mais l'offensive de son modèle
contre l'ukraine à déjouer ces
pronostics la russie je vous donne le
rôle pas je prends le pari n'envahira
pas lui créer la russie a décidé de
frapper l'ukraine je condamne sans
réserve cet usage de la force
en 2017 marine le pen avait déjà les
yeux de chimène pour le maître du
kremlin et un emprunt russe dans les
caisses de son parti aujourd'hui elle
doit se justifier
je le rencontre parce qu'on est deux ans
après le bataclan je leur entente parce
que je considère que la russie peut être
un allié dans la lutte contre le
fondamentalisme islamiste cette vision
là c'est celle là que moi je partageais
pour le coup à l'époque avec emmanuel
macron
mélenchon l'insoumis mélenchon
l'incompris le candidat maintient une
posture d'équilibriste en dénonçant
aussi l'otan dans cette guerre dans
cette affaire vous considérez vous que
c'est l'otan l'agresseur ou que ce sont
les russes
pour moi
depuis le début je dis si vous essayer
d'établir l'otan la frontière de la
russie en ukraine vous aurez un incident
majeur donc je pense ne pas m'être
trompé
pour valérie pécresse une occasion en or
de discréditer ses rivaux il y a eu des
déclarations un très
très forte en faveur de monsieur poutine
de la part d'un jean luc mélenchon d'un
eric zemmour d'une marine le pen je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ça les discrédite
vraiment pour gouverner la france mais
derrière son assurance valérie pécresse
poussent un ouf de soulagement la
nouvelle carrière russe de l'ancien
premier ministre françois fillon
commencez à déteindre sérieusement sur
sa campagne il a démissionné sous la
pression
finalement la guerre en ukraine
rassemble une gauche divisée jadot
taubira hidalgo unis contre le despote
la candidate ps en tant que maire de
paris fait illuminé la tour eiffel et en
profite pour faire vibrer les valeurs de
gauche et nous la gauche européenne
républicaine sociale nous n'hésitons pas
dans ces moments là nous sommes toujours
avec les agresser les oppresser avec le
droit d'un peuple a décidé de son destin
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
et on l'est vu antoine les plus fervents
défenseurs du kremlin jusqu'ici ont
changé bracke n ya absolument
condamnation sans réserve de l'invasion
russe pour certains agression de l'otan
pour d'eau donc vous l'aurez compris
cette guerre non en ukraine n'a pas été
sans conséquence dans la classe
politique on en parle tout de suite avec
notre éditorialiste politique roselyne
febvre bonsoir roselyne en soit cette
guerre en ukraine jeudi 06 elle a donc
fait des dégâts politiques également
chez certains candidats on les a vu
quatre blessées le pen zemmour dupont
aignan et mélenchon alors il m poutine
les uns et les autres pour des raisons
différentes
ils ont une admiration où il avait une
admiration qui est aujourd'hui
contrariée on le voit alors ces quatre
personnages sont bien sûr soupçonnait de
poutine ofili l'un c'est pour en quelque
sorte le nationalisme et le retour le
rêve d'une grande russie l'un parce
qu'il aime sa virilité rappelez vous
quand poutine disait à propos des
tchétchènes je vais aller les buts et
jusque dans les chiottes il défend
l'identité russe et il est prêt à tout
on le voit pour la défendre l'un parce
que c'est l'ennemi
et des américains et que ce sont des
méchants les américains quand on écoute
jean luc mélenchon alors toutes ces
raisons là ont un nom c'est le populisme
et la conclusion que l'on peut en tirer
c'est que le populisme bien évidemment
c'est dangereux surtout quand elles sont
dans les mains de quelqu'un comme
vladimir poutine et aujourd'hui on les
regarde s'emberlificoter dans des
explications qui ne convainquent que
même alors la question qui vient à
l'esprit c'est est-ce que ils sont
discrédités dans la course à la
présidentielle en tout cas on voit alors
embarras et leur triste rétropédalage
certains mac ronis pense que les
français ne préféreront se tourner vers
celui qui est à la tête du bateau malgré
les critiques sur ses initiatives
diplomatiques qui n'ont pas marché le
président est aujourd'hui dans la
posture du capitaine dans la tempête
alors hein les français vont-ils donner
le code nucléaire ou thuriféraires de
vladimir poutine 2 est ce que la guerre
en ukraine risque de faire perdre des
points azemmour le pen ou mélenchon
c'est un risque mais ce n'est pas une
certitude en tout cas roselyne emmanuel
ma condition tirer les bénéfices
politiques de cette crise dans les
sondages il gagne deux points au dernier
baromètre ifop ses adversaires eux davis
le président qui a annulé son mythique
de campagne même s'il n'est pas
officiellement candidat meeting prévu ce
week-end à marseille justement l'annoncé
de sa candidature elle doit intervenir
au plus tard vendredi
quelle tournure peut-elle prendre c'est
juste toute la question alors celle d'un
président candidat forcément et non d'un
candidat accessoirement président ce qui
fait la différence avec toutes les
autres compacts en pagne on a vécu pour
l'instant c'est un atout pour lui en
tout cas au jour d'aujourd'hui alors le
président de la république avait un plan
qui était déjà bien ficelé qui était
plus ou moins secrets mais on savait il
y avait au moins un meeting à marseille
qui d'ailleurs vient d'être annulé des
déplacements sur le terrain des débats
type grand débat quand comme on l'a vu
après la crise des gilet jaune et il est
évident que le président va se surpasser
dans le rôle de président plutôt que
dans celui de candidat la priorité bien
évidemment c'est la crise ukrainienne on
l'a compris de toute façon quoique il
décidera de faire ou de dire tout sera
revu par l'actualité donc pour l'instant
il y a à l'elysée il y a bien sûr des
fenêtres de tir sans faire de mauvais
jeu de mots mais voilà tout peut changer
il faudra bien sûr qu'il dise le 4 mars
puisque c'est la date limite sous quelle
forme il annonce qu'il est candidat
alors une simple formalité comme
certains alors on va éviter le fax de
lionel jospin ou en faire un moment
grave et solennel laissant entendre que
lui seul connaît les dossiers les
conséquences et peut-être les solutions
en tout cas on peut imaginer que cette
guerre ne plaît pas bien évidemment à
macron mais en tout cas elle le cerf
merci beaucoup et roselyne et on vous
retrouve d'ailleurs dès demain dans
mardi politique ce sera avec frédéric
rivière de rfi vous recevrez nicolas bay
le député européen et surtout vice
président exécutif désormais du parti
d'eric zemmour reconquête anthony on va
faire un point à maintenant sur les
parrainages nourrit la course aux
parrainages qui elle se poursuit elle
entre dans sa dernière ligne droite même
date limite de dépôt le 4 mars est à
dire ce vendredi on va jeter un oeil à
la dernière mise à jour du conseil
constitutionnel elle date de jeudi
dernier avec eric zemmour notamment le
candidat du parti aux conquêtes qui n'a
pas encore ses parrainages vous
l'apercevez lui en manque 85 marine le
pen également candidate du rassemblement
national elle aussi n'a pas franchi la
barre des 500 parrainages il lui en faut
encore 86 à noter qu'elle pourra compter
sur le parrainage de françois bayroux
nicolas dupont aignan debout la france
lui pend proche du but encore 43
parrainage obtenir à gauche christiane
taubira elle est encore loin du compte
vous l'apercevez 128 seulement pour le
moment du côté de ceux qui ont récolté
leur précieux sésame anthony on retrouve
valérie précresse des républicains
hidalgo du ps mais aussi yannick jadot
pour europe ecologie les verts ça passe
aussi pour fabien roussel le candidat du
parti communiste emmanuel macron même
pas encore candidat lui il a déjà ses
parrainages et nous recevrons dans une
demi heure jean lassalle qui donc lui a
bien obtenu ces parrainages france 22
1022 l'heure du choix c'est déjà fini
merci antoine penot merci roselyne
febvre on pourra évidemment retrouver l
émission sur notre site internet france
24 points comme et et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
restez avec nous paraît direct continue
prochain jean matte et dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]